[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم اهلا بكم في حصات الليله
معكم محمد كريشان وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم
فيه الان تقع واحداثهم
وتتفاعلوا اخرى هذه الصور من العاصمه
الروسيه موسكو ومناسبه الحديث عنها تراشق
جديد بالاتهامات مع كيب المسؤوليه عن عدم
تقدم المسار التفاوضى في حرب دخلت شهرها
الحادي عشر وافاقها لا تبدو واضحه على
الاطلاق
تصلنا هذه الصور في خدم فصل جديد من
التوتر بين الولايات المتحده والصين
عنوانه الجديد جزيره تايوان والتعاون
الامريكي مع
ننتقل الان الى الخرطوم
وعوده دارفور الى الواجهه من جديد وبقوه
بسبب اعمال عنف قبلي سقط اجرها عشرات بين
قتيل وجريح الملف من ابرز احاديث الساعه
في السودان حاليا
وفي مواضيع الحصاد بهذه الليله
[تصفيق]
دعوات لتسريع الانجازات العسكريه الغربيه
لتحقيق النصر
بوتن يبدا استعداده للتفاوض على مسماها
الحلول المقبوله من الجميع ويتهم اوكرانيا
والغرب برفض الطفر ورئاسه الاوكرانيه ترد
عليه بالمتر وتقول ان عليه العوده الى
الواقع
ردا على اقرار واشنطن قانون يزيز تقديم
مساعدات عسكريه فوريه لتايوان الصين تجري
منورات بحريه وجويه قرب الجزيره وتقول ان
علاقتها مع الولايات المتحده تواجه تحديات
خطيره بسبب عنادها في رؤيه بيجين كمنافس
رئيسي
25,000 ناجح جراء تجدد اعمال العنف القبلي
في دارفور السلطات المحليه تعلن حاله
الطوارئ ومجلس السياده يؤكد عزمه فرض السن
بنشر قوه مشتركه بموجب اتفاق جوبا
في الصين التجاره فيروس كورونا بوتيره غير
مسبوقه السلطاته تعلن وقف نشر الحصيله
اليوميه واقليم جوزيان شرقي البلاد يسجل
مليون اصابه يوميا وسط توقعات بتضاعف
العدد
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه كنا ناقشنا معكم اعلان مجلس
السياده السوداني عزمه تحقيق السلام في
دارفور من خلاله نشر القوه المشتركه
المشكله بموجب اتفاق جمعه ياتي ذلك بعد
اعلان حاله الطوارئ بسبب اشتباكات قبليه
جرت الخميس والجمعه بين مزارعين ورعاه في
ولايه جنوب دارفور خلفت 10 قتله و30 جريحا
حسب مصادر محليه فضلا حرق 15 قريه واضرار
زراعيه مختلفه
من شان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم
السؤال الثالث ما اوراق قوه مجلس السياده
لتحقيق السلام في درهم
23% قالوا ان اوراق قوه المجلس تتمثل
اساسا في ارادته السياسيه في ما قال
ثمانيه بالمئه ان مرجعيه اتفاق في جبال
السلام هي ورقه القوه الرئيسيه
بين المراه 69 بالمئه انه لا اوراق قوه
لدى المجلس السيادي على الاطلاق
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم كالعاده دخول صفحه
التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر حاليا
على الشاشه
الرقميه يتجدد يوميا ونتطرقوا خلاله
لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون معنا في الحصاد ايضا
كاميرا الجزيره في مسقط راس ميسي ترصد
ملامح الزمان وتضاريس المكان عبر وجوه
المحتفين بفوز النجم الارجنتيني بكاس
العالم قطر 2022 ولقب افضل لاعب فيها
[موسيقى]
حلول مقبوله من الجميع
لحرب بلاده على اوكرانيا ودون اغلاق
المجال امام مفاوضات محتمله حملت القياده
الاوكرانيه بدورها المسؤوليه في عدم نجاح
مسارات التفاوض حتى الان لبوت نفسها وتقول
ان عليه العوده الى الواقعه
وسطه هدير المعارك على جبهات اوكرانيا
الساخنه يعود الحديث من طرفي الحرب عن
مفاوضات السلام وان وفق محددات متباينه
فلكل من موسكو وكيف منظوره المختلف بشان
كيفيه الوصول الى حل دبلوماسي يؤكد الرئيس
الروسي ان بلاده جاهزه للتفاوض على حلول
مع جميع الاطراف لحل الصراعي في اوكرانيا
ويتهم
وداعيها برفض الجلوس الى طاوله المفاوضات
بوتين اعتبر ان جذور الصراع تعود الافعال
السلطات الاوكرانيه القاسيه ضد المدنيين
في اقليم دوم بس مضطر بلاده الى الدفاع
عنهم فهي بذلك تحمي مصالحها الوطنيه
ومواطنها في المقابل تتهم رئاسه
الاوكرانيه موسكو بعدم الرغبه في التفاوض
وانها تحاول فقط التنصله من مسؤوليتها عن
قتل المدنيين
والرئيسكي يؤكد العزم على مواصله الدفاع
من اراضي اوكرانيا ويؤكد ان الاوكرانيين
سيصنعون ما سماها معجزه العيد هذا العام
بالرغم من الهجمات والتهديدات والابتزاز
النووي والارهاب والهجمات الصاروخيه
قبل الربيع والعشرين من فبراير الماضي اي
يوم عبرت الدبابات الروسيه الحدود
الاوكرانيه كانت موسكو تتحدث عن ضمانات
امنيات يجب تحقيقها لكي لا تستخدم القوه
ضد اوكرانيا وعلى راسها عدم انضمامك للنتو
وعن ضروره تنفيذ اتفاق منسك اثنين الذي
كان يقضي بان يسحب الجيش الاوكراني اسلحته
الثقيله بعيدا عن خطوط التماس مع القوات
الانفصاليه في دنياز وانت تمنح المقاطعتان
الحكم الذاتي لكن الحاله تغير كثيرا بعد
مرور 10 اشهر على اندلاع الحرب فوفق
التقدير الروسي لم تعد لوجانس ودنياسك
وحدهما جزء من اراضي روسيا بل اضيف اليهما
كل من زابولوجيا واخرسون ولا يعرف ان كان
مفهوم الحل المقبول بالنسبه لموسكو يمكن
ان يشمله تخليها عن تلك الخطوات في
المقابل تتمسك اوكرانيا بان الحل يبدا من
سحاب روسيا من اني اراضيها قبل الحديث عن
اي ضمانات وهي لا تتحدث فقط عن الاقاليم
الاربعه بل حتى عن شبه جزيره القرم التي
حسمت موسكو ضمها اليها قبل اكثر من ثمان
سنوات
تطورات وتصريحات قد تشي بان الطريقه نحو
السلام لا يزال بعيدا فحتى تركيا التي
يمكن ان توصف بانها البلد الوحيد الذي
يحظى بثقه الطرفين وسبق له النجاح بتحقيق
اختراقات كما حدث باتفاق تصدير الحبوب صرح
وزير دفاعا خالص يا كار بان الحرب في
اوكرانيا لا يبدو انها ستنتهي بسهوله
وانها ستستمر العام القادم رغم دعوته الى
تحقيق وقف لاطلاق النار لاسباب الانسانيه
على الاقل
مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني اهلا وسهلا بك
عندما يتحدث الرئيس بوتن عن التفاوض لماذا
لا تثق فيه كيف
طبعا
ما تقوم به روسي وانما يقوم به من الحديث
عن مفاوضات ما هو الا خداع اذا هو عندما
وجد ان مشروعه في اجتياحي اوكرانيا قد ايه
فشل بدا يتحدث عن مفاوضات نعم هو فقط مجرد
خداعه والهام
بالاعمده الغربيه لمواصله دعمها لاوكرانيا
لان السلام على الابواب اذا هذا لا علاقه
له بالواقع روسيا ولو نظرنا الى الوقائع
والحقائق على ارض الواقع نرى ان همم روسي
هي من قامت بتجنيد هذا العدد الكبير من
المجندين وكذلك
ما قامت به من جهود لتدريب هؤلاء المجندين
من اجل شني هجوم واسع النظام في بدايه
العام القادم لذلك سبب الوحيد بوراها
الحديث عن مفاوضاته خلق انطباع لدى العالم
بان هنالك مساء للسلامه ان اوكرانيا هي
التي ترفض التفاوض انها هي التي تريد
اطاله امد هذه الحرب وهذا بعيدا كل البعد
عن الواقع وعن الحقيقه ولكن اذا واصل
الرئيس بوتين هذا التمشي ستبدو فعلا
اوكرانيا كمان يرفض التسويه
ولكن بالتاكيد فيما اذا كان هذا الانطباعه
سيصدقه الناس ام لا نحن لا يهمنا راي بعض
الجهات التي
تدعم حرب الكرملين العدائيه لاننا لا
نتمكن من اقناعه بغض النظر عن ما سنفعله
ولكن عن الجانب الاخر حقيقه الامر هي ان
اوكراني الى طالما كانت دوله مسلمه وستبقى
دوله مستعلمه
ولم تبدا هذا الحرب
في خلافه في ذلك هو يعني
هذه حقيقه الامر هو الامر ربما ليس اثار
نقاش اساسا
باسيتو
[موسيقى]
على الدفاع عن نفسها وقادر على استعاده
الاراضي التي احتلت ونحن
بدعم العالم لتحقيق ذلك ونظام بوتين
هو نظام سيفشل وسينهار وما من سبيل الاخر
لان هذا النظام لجا الى القوه وسبب قيام
بذلك هو الفساد الروسي
النظام السلطه الروسي والطلب بقي هذا
النظام فلن يتغير شيء حلول مقبوله للجميع
هكذا قال كتب كيف فهمتم ذلك
اغنيه الساده
سلام بوتن يعتقد انه ليس هنالك ضغوطات
داخليه عليه وعلينا ان نثبت عكس ذلك علينا
ان نعمل مع العالم باسره لاثبات ذلك
هو بخلاف ذلك الامر وسيمتد طالب
اخرى بما في ذلك بعض الدول الشرق الاوسط
ولهذا
احساس
هو امر لا يعنينا ولا نفاوض او نتفاوض مع
مجرم حرب والذي ليس لديه اي تعاطف مع
ضحايا نحن سندافع عن ارضنا
وقدمنا الخطوات
ذات المغزى
واساسها ان تنسحيب روسيا من الاراضي
المعترف بها دوليه ان كل الدول
بخلاف بعض الدول المنبوذه هي من تعترف
بتلك المناطق التي ضمها روسيا عليه من
يغادره هذه الاراضي قبل ان نشرع في
مفاوضات
ونحاسب كل المسؤولين عن جرائم الحرب
والمسؤولين عندي دمار بلدينا وتقديمه الى
العداله وهذا ما سنفعله حقا شكرا جزيلا
لكم الرئيس
سلام ينضم لنا من موسكو مدريد الكاتب
المحلل السياسي الروسي اهلا وسهلا بك
قولوا بوتن بضروره ايجاد حلول مقبوله
للجميع الذي يشير ذلك لانه بدا يتعب من
هذه الحرب
مع العقوبات التي فرضت على روسيا من قبل
دخول الغربيه
ويتم بقتله من قبل الجيش الاوكراني هل
يمكن ان تكون روسي مرتاحه بهذه الامور
فلذلك روسيا تصعر
انهاء هذه الازمه ولكن توجد لدى روسيا
مصالح ولا يمكن تنازل عن تلك المصالح
على ذكر المصالح دائما بوتن وموسكو وتقول
باستمرار نعم للتسويه ولكن همم مع مراعاه
الحقائق على الارض وكانها تقول لها تقول
لك كيف انسوا اراضيكم التي تم احتلالها
ولتقبل بالامر الواقع هذا هل هذا مقبول
انا اعتقد ان هذا يجب ان يكون مقبولا
بسببا نحن قد اعطينا لي السلطات
الاوكرانيه اكثر من فرصه لحفاظ على اراضي
الاوكرانيه مثلا لولا الانقلاب في عام
2014 في كيف لا ما كانت القرم تحت سيطرتها
روسيه الان لو قامت السلطات في كيف بتنفيذ
الاتفاقيه منسك لما كانت لما كان هناك
الانضمام لاربع المناطق الجديده الى روسيا
همم فلماذا يجب على روس التراجع وتخلي عن
تلك المناطق يعني هناك لواقع الذي قد
تشاكل نتيجه بعض الاهداف نتيجه تطورات على
ساحه القتال ويعني لن اكون وصالحين كل
المفاوضات بعض الاملاء القتاليه همم تجري
مبنيا على الواقع الواقعه موجود على ساحه
القتال روسيا قد وسعت همم اراضيها دمت بعد
المناطق نتيجه الاستفتاء
الحال يجب ان ناخذ كفي عن الاعتبار همم
انت همم عندما تنطلق المفاوضات حول
مسائل الاخرى مثل المسائل الاهميه مسائل
الحياد اوكرانيا وغيره مسائل الجيش
الاوكراني ويلم هناك ولكن كلمه الواقعه
التي تشير اليها الان تعتبر تدمير لمنطق
القانون الدولي بمعنى اي دوله يمكن ان
تذهب الى جارتها بغض النظر على اعتبارات
تحت الاراضيه وتقول هذا هو الواقع عليكم
ان تقبل به هذا غير مقبول الان في العالم
طبعا اذا تركنا اسرائيل يعني
هذا لي
س صاحبي الموقف الروسي من الازمه في
اوكرانيا بسبب روسيا قامت باعتراف
جمهوريتين
قبل الدخول الى الى اوكرانيا ومبنين على
الاطاله من هاتين الجمهوريتين قد قامت
باجراء العمليه العسكريه كذلك روسيا اجرت
سلسله الاستفتاءات في القرم وفي غيرها من
المناطق التي انضمت الى صفوف الاراده
الروسيه لذلك قانونيا انا لا ارى اي مشكله
بالنسبه
طبعا واضح تمام من ال- ال-
الاولاد كنت اهل الامريكيه دول الغربيه
تشكك همم
ولكن رؤوسك على الاقل في الاستفتاءات وتلك
الاستفتاءات هذا شارد بان السكان المحلي
لانضمام الى الاراده الروسيه فلذلك همم
قانونيا كل الامور طيبه وروسي ملتزم لولا
[موسيقى]
تصرفات الاوكرانيه اللاما كان هناك كل تلك
المشاكل بنسبه اللي اوكرانيا شكرا لك
من موسكو
على الصعيد الميداني تتواصلوا المعارك
وعمليات القصف المتبادل على طول الجبهه
الاوكرانيه وتزامنت مع دوي صفارات الانذار
في عدد من المدن الاوكرانيه تحسبا لغارات
جويه الروسيه وبينما اعلن الجانب
الاوكراني ان القوات الروسيه تجددت قصفها
لمقاطعات خيرسون
لايف وان الجيش الاوكراني في المقابل وجه
ضربات للقوات الروسيه وامسك بخطوط القتال
لا سيما في المناطق الريفيه لزبروشيه ركز
الجانب الروسي على النتائج الخسائر
المدنيه التي تم تسجيلها جراء اوكرانيا
على المناطق التي يسيطر عليها في لوجان
سقوط صواريخ من طراز ايمارس الامريكيه
في خرسان قالت الاداره العسكريه ان
المدينه تتعرضت للقصف المدفعيه وقذائف
الهاون نحو احدى وسبعين مره ليله الماضيه
قتل فيها 13 مدنيا واصيب العشرات من
جانبها افادت الطوارئ الحكوميه الاوكرانيه
بمقتل ثلاثه من افراد اجهزه الطوارئ اثناء
ازاله الغام في منطقه جيتمير
وفي اقليم الدونتس شرق اوكرانيا قال مسؤول
عسكريا اوكراني ان القوات الروسيه تتقسست
منطقه
عده ما ادى الى اصابه امراه بجروح كما مثل
المسؤول الاوكراني مشاهد قال انها توثق
الدمار الذي لحق بمؤسسه صناعيه استهدفت
القوات الروسيه في مدينه كريماتوس واقتصرت
الاضرار على الخسائر المادي
هذا وقد اكد رئيس الروسي بلادي بور بوتين
ان بلاده قادره تماما على تدمير صواريخ
باتريات الخاصه بالدفاع الجوي اذا قدمتها
الولايات المتحده الى اوكرانيا وكانت
وكاله تاس قد نقلت عن السفير الروسي لدى
واشنطن ان موسكو ابلغت الولايات المتحده
ان انظمه باتريوت ستكون اهدافا مشروعه
للضربات في اوكرانيا هذا التهديد ياتي
بعيده اعلاني واشنطن تزويده بمنظومات
الصواريخ باتريوت بعد مطالبات اوكرانيه
طويله
تعد فتره بنسختها لاحدث بي اي سي ثلاثه
منظومه دفاعا جوي ارض جو تحمل القذيفه
منها 16 صاروخا يضافوا لها مركبه الرادار
وغرفه التحكم يصل مدى الصاروخ سبعين
كيلومترا وبارتفعا يبلغ 24 كم
يكشفون نظام الرادار الارضي الخاص
بالمنظومه الهدفه ويتتبعه في دائره قطرها
يقدر ب 80 كم
نحو الهدف لتفجيره قبل وصوله لوجهه
للمسار وتصحيحه وهو قادر على اعتراض
صواريخ البالستيه وصواريخ الكروز وبعض
انواع الطائره
فهي تعمل على تامين المجال الجوي ليدو
وليانيته في اوروبا الشرقيه ومنها رومانيا
وبولندا كما توجد في دول اوروبيه اخرى
كالمانيا وهولندا وي اسبانيا لكنه يتخلى
منظومه الى المعركه لن يكون بسرعه
المتوقعه نظرا للحاجات الى تدريب
الاوكرانيين على استخدامها ولذي قد يستغرق
عده اشهر حسب مسؤولين امريكيين
قدم الغرب مساعدات عسكريه لاوكرانيا شملت
انظمه الدفاع جوي متطوره لكن الجيش لا
يزال يعتمد الى حد كبير على معدات من
الحقبه السوفياتيه للدفاع عن المدنيه
فتدريب الافراد على استخدام الاسلحه
الجديده يستغرق وقتا مراسلوا شبكه الجزيره
تشارلز ستران بولت التقى عددا من اعضاء
فرقه الدفاع الجوي المتنقله في العاصمه
موجها الى السماء وفي حاله تاهب هذا
السلاح المضاد للطائرات سوفيه الصنع انتج
عام 82
متنقله يحاولون حمايه العاصمه الاوكرانيه
والمناطق المحيطه بها من المسيرات الروسيه
المتفجره والهجمات الصاروخيه
بعض الاخيره
هذا السعودي
يقول القائد هنا انها فعاله ويصل مداها 6
كيلو مترات لكن غالبا ما يجدون صعوبه في
اسقاط الطائرات بدون طياره التي تستخدمها
روسيا لاستهداف في شبكه الكهرباء
القوات الروسيه نفذت ملا يقل عن 1000 هجوم
بطائرات مسيره وصواريخ كروز سادفت عبرها
البنيه التحتيه للطاقه في الفتره الاخيره
معظم الهجمات المماثله لهذا يجري اعتراضها
من انقطاع التيار الكهربائي ونقص التدفئه
في ظل الشتاء فارس
الولايات المتحده الاسبوع الماضي
بوكيمون
ستستخدم فقط لحمايه الاهداف المحتمله
الاهم ولا يمكن نشرها لاعتراض الطائرات
بدون طيار وصواريخ كروز
الان صوت صفاره انذار بعيده انه انذار
دفاع جوي وهذا يعني ان هؤلاء الرجال يجب
ان يتحرك
ويمكره بسهوله
في الساعه تقريبا ولكن فقط في حاله تركيز
عليها
الجزيره
[موسيقى]
مشتركه وتدريبات الهجوم
حول جزيره تايوان وقال ان هذه المناورات
تاتي ردا على التصعيد والاستفزاز
الامريكيه التونيه وفقا تعبيره حديث ياتي
بعيده تمرير مجلس النواب الامريكي مشروع
قانوني موازنه التمويل الحكوميه للعام
المقبل متضمنا انفاقا عسكريا يسمحوا
بمساعده امنيه تصل قيمتها الى 10 مليار
دولار ومبيعات اسلحه سريعه
صورتها الوادعه قد تغالطك فربما كانت هذه
الارض على حافه الحرب ذا كما يخشاه
متابعون للتوتر الامريكي الصيني المتصاعد
بشان تايوان لم يبدا اليوم هذا السيجال
حول الجزيره الواقعه في المحيط الهادي
والتي يسكنها اكثر من 23 مليون نسمه
المسافه بينها وبين البر الصيني لا تتجاوز
140 كلم
ترى الولايات المتحده في تايوان جبهه
الدفاع الاولى عن حلفائها من جيران
الجزيره ودول اخرى بجنوب شرقي اسيا اما
مضموها المحتمل من قبل الصين فيعني
السيطره على الممرات الرئيسيه للسفن وعلى
حركه الامدادات كما يوسع من نطاق الطيران
الصيني 150 ميلا بحريا شرقا بما يرفع
القدره على ضرب اهداف في اليابان وجزيره
جوانا الامريكيه ويهدد قواعد واشنطن في
المنطقه
تعتبر الصين تايوان المتمتعه بحكم الذاتي
جزءا من اراضيها ولم تستبعد يوما احتمال
استخدام القوه للسيطره عليها وتلوح
الولايات المتحده بالتدخل عسكريا في حال
اقدمت بيجين على ذلك لم يحدث الاسواق بعد
لكن حول الجزيره يجري الجيش الصيني
تدريبات تشمل توجيها ضربات عسكريه في
البحر والمجال الجوي تضع بيجن نشاط هداك
في سياق الرد على ما تعتبره مؤامرات
واستفزازات من قبل
واشنطنباي لكن من الواضح ان الامر صله
المباشره باعتماد الرئيس الامريكي قانون
تفويض الدفاع الوطني الامريكي
اذ يجيز زياده المساعدات العسكريه للجزيره
ومبيعات اسلحه فوريه تصل قيمتها الى 10
مليار دولار طبيعي ان ترحب تايبي بالقرار
وتستا منه بيجننك بشده
الصينيه ترى في القرار ما يهدد السلامه
والاستقرار في مضيق تايوان ويضعوا العلاقه
مع واشنطن امام تحدي خطير لا تقيم
الولايات المتحده
مع تايوان لكنها اهم مدعم دولي واكبر مزود
دولي لها بالاسلحه قبل ثلاثه شهور كانت
احدث صفقات واشنطن العسكريه مع تايوان وهي
الاكبر منذ تولي بيضنا الرئاسه بمبلغ
اجمالا قدره مليار ومئه مليون دولار تشمل
الصفقه 60 صاروخا مضاده للسفن قادره على
اغراق السفن حربيه وصواريخ قصيره المدى
قدره على اعتراض صواريخ وطائرات بدون تيار
وتضمنت صفقه عقد صيانه لنظام الرادارات
التايوالي الصين تدين دوما ما تراه صفقات
تقوض سيادتها واستقرار مضيقتي وان لا تكف
عن دعوه واشنطن الى احترام مصالح الصينيين
الاساسيين ولا تكف واشنطن في المقابل على
تاكيد انها لن تسمح لبنج باعاده تشكيل
النظام الدولي
سنعود لملف الخلاف الشائكي والوجودي بين
الصين وتايوان في فقره المتابعه ضمن
الحصاد لنستعرض المواقف والاحداث عبر
مساراتها التاريخيه وجيوس سياسيه
[موسيقى]
انا مدير الشرطه في ولايه جنوب دارفور في
السودان مقتل نحوي 11 شخصا بينهم اثنان من
افراد القوات النظاميه واصابه اكثر من 20
اخرين وتعرض سبع قرن للحرق بشكل كامل جراء
اشتباكات قبليه وقال جنوب دارفور حامد
هنون في تصريحات صحفيه ان لجنه امن
الولايه دفعت بتعزيزات عسكريه قوامها نحو
60 سياره مسلحه و 400 من عناصر القوات
المشتركه لتامين القرى المتاثره بتلك
الاشتباكات
واعلن مسؤول الطوارئ في مفوضيه العون
الانساني بولايه الجنوبي دارفور عثمان
ابراهيم ان عدد النازحين من القرى
المتاثره بلغ اكثر من 15 الفجر
مره اخرى ينفجر الوضع في اقليم دارفور هذه
المره في شرق منطقه بليله بولايه جنوب
دارفور حيث سقط قتلى وجرحى في اشتباكات
قبليه طيله الايام الثلاثه الماضيه
فرضت السلطات المحليه اثر ذلك حظر للتجول
في المنطقه مسرح الاحداث من الرابعه عصرا
الى الرابعه من صباح اليوم التالي بتوقيت
جرينتش بعض الهدوء الحذر عرفته المدينه
اليوم لكن حده الصدامات خلال الايام
الثلاثه الماضيه دفعت مئات الاسر باتجاه
مخيمات النازحين فرارا من القرى التي شهدت
هجمات الجماعات المسلحه
وذاك ما حدا بالمنسقيه العامه للنازحين
واللاجئين في السودان الى اطلاق نداء عاجل
لفتح ممرات امنه نحو المخيمات
والصراع في اقليم دارفور قصه ممتده في
تاريخ السودان القريب فهو بالاساس صراع
على الموارد تعود جذوره الى عام 2003 بين
القبائل العربيه التي يهنوا الرعيه وتمتاز
بالترحال والقبائل ذات الاصول الافريقيه
المستقره التي تنتهي الزراعه
يتهم النظام السابق باهمال هذا الاقليم
فراغ ما اسهامه الكبير في الدخل القومي
السوداني بثرواته الحيوانيه والزراعيه فان
الحكومات المركزيه كانت تحريمه من مشاريع
التنميه
اندلعت لذلك مواجهه متكرره بين القبائل
التي نحت نحو التسلح من اجل السيطره على
المراعي والاراضي الزراعيه الخصبه وتطور
الوضع الى تشكيل جماعات وحركات مسلحه ينتج
كل منها نهجا يدعم مسالا قبليا وسياسيا
محددا استمر صراع القبائل عقب سقوط الرئيس
السابق عمر البشير حتى وقعت الحركات
المسلحه اتفاق جوبا للسلام مع الحكومه
الانتقاليه في الثالث من اكتوبر عام 2020
لكن اعمال العنف رغم ذلك لم تتوقف وحتى
قوات حفظ السلام الدوليه الافريقيه
يونايتد التي انتشرت في الاقليم من من
2007 بهدف حمايه المدنيين انهى مجلس الامن
الدولي مهامها بنهايه العام 2020
ومعنى من الخرطوم الدكتور عمر الخير مدير
المركز السوداني للديمقراطيه والتنميه
اهلا وسهلا بك دكتور اعلان حاله الطوارئ
هل يمكن ان يطوق
تدهور الوضع اكثر
مرحبه وعليكم السلام ورحمه الله تعالى
وبركاته
الحقيقه
الاعلان الطوارئ هو قد يساهم كثيرا في
استقرار الوضع على ما هو عليه ولكن همم
ليست هذه الحلول المطلوبه لهذا النوع من
من النزاعات والصراعات او العنف صراحه
يمكن الكلام ده اذا جينا نظرنا ليه يعني
عفوا
المطلوبه دكتور
طبعا احنا نعرف تماما انه منطقه دارفور
يعني هي طبيعه الاجتماعيه والقبليه نفسها
وطبيعه الصناعه ظل موجود في دارفور يعني
منذ الالفينات يعني بدايات الافينات حتى
الان هو
ناتج جزء منه اول حاجه لطبيعه القبليه
لهذه القبائل او هذه هذا المجتمع والجزء
الاخر ناتج عن طبيعه الصراع الموجود على
على الارض حول الارض وحول الموارد
وبالتالي همم في همم هذا النوع من من
الصراعات في ظل همم مرحله انتقاليه في
غياب حقيقه السلطه وغيا
للقانون لسعه القانون في المنطقه همم
سيعرض هذه المناطق الانفجارات مختلفه
والاذاعات مختلفه وبالتالي يلزم الحل
الامني ليست هو الحل الامثل الان وانما
الحل المطلوب حجه حلول في البدايه هو هناك
حلول سياسيه متعلقه بانهاء النزاع تماما
يعني
بعد اذنك الملفت ان القوه المشتركه التي
كان يفترض ان ان ان تنتشر هناك بموجب
اتفاق جوبا اتفاق جوبا من عام 2020 ومع
ذلك لم تنشر لماذا
لوحده من الاشياء دي واحده من الاشياء
تكلمنا عنها ان في اسباب سياسيه اللي هي
متعلقه بالترتيبات الامنيه
الناتي عن اتفاق جوبا الاخيره هذا كان
يفترض انه يكون في تركيبات امنيه يعني تتم
بحيث ان يحصل همم ترتيب
للجيوش الحركات المسلحه وفي نفس الوقت بعد
ذلك ايضا يحصل همم يعني همم فرض اللي
هيبقى السلطه والقانون
الاسلحه الموجود عند كثير همم المنتشره
معروف ان في في في المنطقه وبدون بدون
بدون
سلاح بدون فرد هيبقى السلطه ووجود ترتيبات
سياسيه متعلقه بالجواد المتعلقه بالجانب
السياسي اللي هي بالساعد في ترتيبات
الامنيه انا ممكن تساعد على هذا شكرا على
انهاء النزاع وعلى القضاء على هذه النوع
من النزاعات والعنف اللي بيتكلم عنه الان
شكرا حتى احنا بنتكلم على العنفي بيتكلم
عنه ناتج عن عن جانب اجتماعي وليست سياسي
شكرا ولكن لم يتطور اول ما يدخل في الجانب
القبلي بيؤثر بعد ذلك على الاوضاع كلها
شكرا لك دكتور عمر الخير كنت معنا من
الخرطوم شكرا
[موسيقى]
الى اخبار جائعتي قرون التي يبدو انها
عاده للتفاعل بشكل اكبر على الاقل في
الصين حيث اعلنت سلطات الصحيه هناك انها
ستتوقف بدءا من اليوم عن نشر اعداد
الاصابات والوفيات بالفيروس هذا الاعلان
ياتي رغم الارتفاع القياسي في اعداد
الاصابات سجل اقليم جينك شرقيه البلاد
اصابات يوميه تقدروا بالمليون يوميا وسط
التوقعات بان يتضاعف هذا العدد في الايام
المقبله
هل يعوض شبح كورونا الاطلال براسه في ذكره
الثالثه لم تتعافى البشريه تماما من موجات
الجائحه رغم اعتبار القيود والاغلاقات
جزءا من الماضي الا في مسقط راس الفيروس
تعيش الصين واجواء عصيبه تعيد تفكير بمثل
هذه الايام من اواخر 2019 واوائل 2020
مليون اصابه يوميه تسجل في اقليم
البلاد والتوقعات تشير للمزيد خلال ايام
وفي شنغهاي حثه السلطات الناس على البقاء
في منازلهم خلال اعياد الميلاد لكن مستشفى
بالمدينه توقع ان يصاب نصف السكان البالغ
عددهم 25 مليون بالفايروس بحلول نهايه
الاسبوع المقبل وتوقعت حكومه مقاطعه شرق
البلاد ان يصاب ثمانون بالمئه من سكانها
اي نحو سته وثلاثين مليون شخص بالفايروس
حتى مارس اثار قادم
تصاعد اعداد الاصابات لم يقنع قطاعات من
المواطنين بقبول استمرار القيود الوقائيه
التي لم تكت تنقشع طوال السنوات الثلاث
الماضيه فاندلعت احتجاجات قبل اسابيع الغت
السلطات على اثرها مطلع ديسمبر اجراءات
الاغلاق والفحوص والحجر وقيود السفر التي
اثرت سلبا على النمو الاقتصادي انتقال وصف
بالمفاجئ من سياسه صفر كورونا ذات القيود
الثقيله الصارمه الى التوسع في تخفيف
القيود لكن على واقع تزايد الاعداد مؤخرا
اعلنت لجنه الصحه الوطنيه بالصين التوقف
عن نشر البيانات اليوميه لاصابات فيروس
كورونا ووفياته
تخفف السلطات قيود الوقايه لكنها تشدد
قيودا اخرى على التناول الاعلامي للفيروس
ومستجداته والرغم الاعداد الصادمه تواصل
وسائل الاعلام الحكوميه التقليل من خطوره
الموجه الجديده
المراوحه الصينيه بين الاغلاق وعدم
الاغلاق تطرح تساؤلات في ظل التصاعد
اللافت في اعداد الاصابات حول مخاطر
اندلاع موجه عالميه جديده تنطلق من الصين
نحو عالم اثقلته قيود الجائحه فاز لها
اتراه يتحمل العوده اليها طوعا او كرها
من معنا من مليو الفرنسيه البروفيسور يحيى
عبد المؤمن المكي المتخصص في علم
الفيروسات والخبير السابق لدى منظمه الصحه
العالميه اهلا وسهلا
هل نخشى ان نكون قد عدنا الى نقطه البدايه
كل المشاهدين الكلام
لا نعود الى البدايه لا سيدي الكريم ربما
الصين تعود الى البدايه وهذا له تفسير
العلمي
البدايه لانه
خبره ثلث سنوات لنا عده لقاحات على الاقل
تسعه انواع من اللقاحات لان كذلك خبره في
تاهب المستشفيات والدول الاوروبيه وفرنسا
منذ اسبوع كانت تعيش الموجه التاسعه
وفرنسا الاسبوع الماضي كنا فوق
65,000 اصابه يوميا 22000 دخول المستشفى
بيزيد 2200 في العنايه الانعاش لكن لم
نتعلم كثير لانه السيد بوتين اوكرانيا
والسعاده والفرحه الكبيره هي قطر والكاس
العالم التي افرحتنا مع الفريق المغربي
فربما انزلنا ان نتكلم عن هذا اليوم الخوف
العوده نعم في السين لانه السينما يزيد
1000 مليار 1500 مليون نسمه لم ي جيدا
الصين رغم انه انتجت احد لم وكان له الحزم
في الموجه الاولى وفي بدء همم الجائحه
بدايه الجائحه لكن لم يقح جيدا لقح اقل من
50% ال- ال- ال- الفئه من المواطنين الذين
هم اكثر اهتماما ما يفوق 75 سنه
اكثر اليوم والموجه كبيره وما همم ربما
اخفقت فيه السين هو كيف تتحكم ما بين
الحجر الصحي الدائم والقيود الشديده التي
اجملت المواطنين في بدايه الجائحه
وبعثت سنوات تقريبا كيف حاولت لكن لم تنجح
لان المواطنين بالاضرابات كما تفضلته في
التقرير الجيد والهام جدا لنا بالمعلومات
هنا همم تزعزع النظام في الصين هل كيف
يدير هذه الموجه والدليل بانه الفيروس
المنتشر اليوم في العالم وعاد الى الصين
لم يظهر في الصين من سابقا البي كيو11 هو
من اوميكرون ولكن لم ينتشر في السن سابقا
فبالتغيراته الكثيره تقريبا ما يفك 50
تغير تركيبه جينيه للبروتينات والاحماض
الامينيه في هذا النسخه فاصبح كانه فيروس
جديد يصيب الشعب الصيني وكذلك دول اسيا
الاخرى مثل كوريا وماليزيا واندونيسيا
فهذا التخوف الكبير من هذا الفيروس اليوم
بينما اوروبا كذلك تصاب حاليا بهذا الموجه
التاسعه نعم سيدي شكرا لك بروفيسور يحيى
عبد المؤمن مكي كنت معنا من مدينه ليون
الفرنسيه
الى موضوع اخر اكثر بهجه بالتاكيد الذي
يحتفي سكان مدينه روساريو في ولايه سانتا
في شمال شرق الارجنتين مسقط راسي النجمه
ليونيل ميسي يحتفلون بفوزه بكاس العالم
قطر 2022 ويستذكرون بدايته في ملاعب
الاحياء قبل انتقاله الى الاحتراف في
برشلونه وقد تجمع عدد كبير من سكان
المدينه في الحي الذي ولد فيه ميسي وفي
مقر اقامته الحالي بعد عودته الى الولايه
عاقبه تتويجه ببطوله العالم مراسل الجزيره
حسن مسعود زار مسقط راس ميسي ولخص لنا من
هناك رحله النجم الارجنتينيه في هذا
التقرير
ميسي اسطوره خطى تاريخها هذا الطفل الذي
يروي كيف كان يلعب في نادي الحي صغيرا
بمسقط راسه بروسريو ويحلم باللعب مع
المنتخب منها انطلق الى العالميه وحقق
اكثر مما كان يحلم به مع ابن مدينته
ديماريه لجلب اليها والى بلاده كاس العالم
اختار متحف مدينته بولايه سانتافي وضع
نسخه اصليه منه الى جانب صوره ظاهره
مارادونا ليؤكد ان ابنهم بات ايقونه
ارجنتينيا كذلك والى جانبه عدد من نجوم
المنتخب
اكبر النجوم في كره القدم وقد اثبت ذلك في
اخر مونديال حيث خرج منها النجم الكبير
ميسي وهنا نحتفظ بقميص طفولته
قبل انتقاله الى برشلونه بعمر 13 عاما لكن
تحقيق اول اهدافه كان هنا في نادي كردبه
حيث يسترجع زميله ذكرياتهما
معانا
كنت اشعر انه مختلفون واثبت ذلك في كل شيء
في طريقه لاعبه وموهبته وشخصيته
لا ينسى مدير نادي حركات واداء ميسي
الاستثنائي بين اقرانه في زوايا هذا
الملعب رغم معاناته حينها من نقص النمو
الشهيره التي قالها بلهجه ابناء المدينه
وقد حافظ على وفئه لها
العلاج وكلنا نتمنى علاجه لكن لم نستطيع
كان يتمتع باداء غير عادي لدينا صور له في
هذا الملعب وهو يتجاوز اللاعبين بمهاره
منذ صغاره
يزين ابناء حيه الطريق المؤديه الى منزله
في مسقط راسه فرحا باحضاره النجمه الثالثه
لبلدهم وتتنوع اشكال تعبيرهم البعض علق
رساله شكر على باب منزل العائله والاخر
ترك توقيعه او رسمه لوحه وهو ينظر الى
حلمه وقد بات حقيقه
اما في اول ملعب داسته قدما ميسي على
زاويه الحي فيلعب اطفال حين تسالهم عن
حلمهم يجيبون
بس الكاراتي اتمنى لقاء ميسي شخصيا وان
اصبح مثله
لقاء ذاته يتمناه ابناء الولايات التي
اختار نجمهم احد منتجعاتها للاستجمام بعد
المونديال الى الولايات التي خرج منها عاد
ليو ميسي للاستراحه بعد ما حقق حلما
مدينته وبلده وضفير بكاس العالم انها قصه
ظاهره ارجنتينيه ثانيه مع المنتخب الوطني
بعد الراحل دييغو مارادونا يشتعل الجدل في
المقارنه بينهما لكن يبقى انما يجمعهما هو
تحقيق بطوله العالم لبلدهما حسن مسعود
الجزيره سانتفه
[موسيقى]
عوده الى ملف الصين وتايوان حيث يحاول
استدعاء الخلفيه التاريخيه للنزاع المستمر
منذ اكثر من سبعه حروف
من الجزر جنوب شرقي اسيا المحيط الهادي
ويفصلها مضيق تايوان غربا عن مقاطعه فوجان
الصينيه
كيلو متر
قصه تايوان بدات عام
1949 عندما فرط اليها الحكومه الوطنيه
الكومنتات برئاسه تشانغ كاشيك وذلك اثرا
انتصار الشيوعيين في الحرب الاهليه
وسيطرتهم على بر الصين الرئيسي
تعرف تايوان تعرف نفسها بجمهوريه الصين
الوطنيه و بانها دوله ذات سياده بينما
تعدها واشنطن عفوا جمهوريه الصين الشعبيه
وعاصمتها بيجين جزءا من اراضيها وتسميها
تايوان الصينيه ضمن ما تعرف بسياسه سين
واحده ضل التايوان ممثلا عن الصين
التاريخيه حتى عام
1971 ان تم الاعتراف بجمهوريه الصين
الشعبيه ومنحت بجان وقتها مقعد الامم
المتحده الذي كانت تشغله كيف تحول
التايوان منذ مطلع الالفيه الثالثه الى
دوله ديمقراطيه حيث ادخلت اصلاحات على
نظامها السياسي مكنه شخصيه من خارج حزب
الكومنتال من الوصول الى السلطه عبر
الانتخابات ومن اجل استعادتها طرحت الصين
صيغه تعرف باسم دوله واحده
ونظاما تمنحه بموجبها تايوان استقلاليه
كبيره لكن العارضه قبل بالرفض بينما
تزايدت تهديدات بجين في السنوات الاخيره
بضم الجزيره ولو بالقوه
اللازمه الامر
معنا الان من العاصمه التايوانيه تايبي
براين هو الكاتب والمحلل السياسي اهلا
وسهلا بك برايك سيد هو الى متى سيستمر هذا
الاشكال بين
تايوان والصين
واوي
التعريف باننا
تايوانيين
بالتالي انا لا ارى ان هذه المشكله قد
تذهب بعيدا السلطات الصينيه هي تدعم
بسيطرتها على تايوان
المطالب الصينيه
اذا لم تغير الصين فان الخلاف سيستمر على
عشان بينما حقائق الجغرافيا عندما ترى
الجغرافيا هذا العملاق الصيني مع جزيره
تايوان تصبح حقائق الجغرافيا غير حسابات
السياسه
في حقيقه الامر اذا ما نظرنا الى
هنالك ايه
نرى انه هنالك تحركات صينيه ربما
لعمليه عسكريه هذا الامر سيؤثر على الصين
وسيكون امرا مؤثرا بمعنى ان الحكومه
الصينيه قد تضحي بالك حياه الكثير من
الشباب الصينيين من اجل السيطره على
بالتالي ليس هنالك حاجه للقيم ذلك لكن ال-
حكومه الصينيه اعتقد انها لديها خطا في
هذا الموضوع علينا ان ننتظر اذا ما كانت
الحكومه الصينيه همم انها بعد 40
محاربتها باي حرف
اي محاوله لعمليه عسكريه ستكون هنالك قوي
لها ولكن مهما مهما قدمت الولايات المتحده
من مساعدات عسكريه الى تايوان هي لا شيء
امام القوه العسكريه الصينيه هل هذا في
وارد حسابات
بالتاكيد لان الصين
لمده 40 عاما
واعتقد انه اذا ما كان هنالك
بالتالي الصين تحتاج ان تكون حظيره جدا
بعد
تاثير الاقتصادي للجائحه والمعاناه التي
تحملتها عندما كان هنالك
رغبه بغزوه وانا اعتقد انه سيكون خطا
كبيرا وبدون اي شروط مسبقه اذا ما كان
هنالك تدخل اعتقد انه سيكون
ستكون انا وضع الصعبه للغايه
[موسيقى]
كل هذا كل هذه الامور تعتمد على عدم قيام
تايوان باي شيء لكن يكون هنالك مع ذلك
الخطر بشكل كبير من الصين تحركت
عسكريه
فستتدخل واشنطن عسكريه هل فعلا تعولونا
على ذلك
وتثقون فيه
يعني
اعيد السؤال اذا اذا ما هاجمت الصين هل
فعلا تعويلكم على
الولايات المتحده
تعويلا في محله
100%
انا
الذي لا اول على وصول السؤال الى السيد هو
كنا نتحدث عن علاقه الصين وعلاقه الصين
بتيوان والى اي مدى يمكن ان تراهم على
الدعم الامريكي في حال نسب اي نساء عسكري
ينضم الينا الان من بيجين فيكتور جاو نائب
رئيس مركز الصين والعولمه
هذا الاشكال بين الصين
تايوان برايك
هل يمكن ان يتطور الى ما هو اسوا من الوضع
الحالي
اذا الاشكال بين الصين وتايوان انعكس حتى
في هذه المقابله بين الضيفين الصيني
والتايواني الضيف الصيني غير جاهز اذا
اعود للضيف التايواني السيد هو اذا اعيد
سؤالي الذي طرحته عليك قبل قليل هل يمكن
لتايوان ان تعول على الدعم العسكري
الامريكي لمقاومه الصين
ان الولايات المتحده بدايه تعتبر ان هذه
الامور امور محليه بالتالي لا تعتمد
تايوان على الدعم الخارجي بالرغم ذلك فان
الكثير من التقديرات والخسائر التي
ستتكبدها الصين في مساله الخسائر البشريه
اذا ما سيطرت على تايوان هي تعتمد على عم
عدم اخذ بنظر الاعتبار التدخل الامريكي
مره اخرى اقول ان الصين لما هتاخذ حربا
لاربعين عاما لان خوض الحرب مع تايوان
اعتقد انه منذ الحرب العالميه الثانيه
سيكون ضربه قاسمه
للطبقه الوسطى في الصين وتاثير كبير على
القوه العسكريه فاننا ناخذ بكل هذه الامور
شكرا
[موسيقى]
من العاصمه التايوانيه
يفترض ان همم يكون معنا سيد فيكتور جاو
لكن للاسف لم
امكانيه الاتصال به وهذا ليس موقفا من
الجزيره مع تايوان او ضد الصين هكذا شاءت
الامور شكرا لكما همم
نعم
[موسيقى]
البدايه كانت من الصين وكل الخوف الان ان
تكون العوده من الصين كذلك
الصين التي حققت نجاح كبيره
يضعون الان ايديهم على قلوبهم خوفا من
عوده لذلك الكابوس الذي كدر حياه الجميع
في السنوات الماضيه واوقف عجله التنميه
تقريبا لا احد طبعا يتمنى ذلك بقدر ما
يامر ان يكون العالم قد اصبح الان اكثر
حنكه في التعامل مع كورونا وصولا الى
القضاء التام عليه في القريب العاجل نتمنى
لكم جميعا الصحه والعافيه وندعوا الله ان
يستجيب واعينا حفظ الله الجميع وتصبحون
على خير
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]